welcome everybody
thank you for coming uh on this uh
nicest day of the year so far i think
our shulman lecturer for today is
professor ian phillips
ian is taught in the philosophy
departments at oxford where i think he
got his undergraduate degrees at
university college london where i
believe he got his phd in the university
of birmingham he's also taught in the
cognitive science program at princeton
for the last several years he has been
the bloomberg distinguished professor at
johns hopkins university and this is not
just a fancy title but it's actually
sort of a new exciting kind of thing
bloomberg professors must be fully
cross-appointed in multiple departments
and so ian is a professor of philosophy
and also a professor of psychological
and brain sciences
ian is one of our field's leading
philosophers of perception he works on
many many different topics with a
special focus on the perception of time
visual adaptation blind site object
representations many different aspects
of visual awareness and the lack thereof
and he also does some
intriguing secret work on silences and
shadows
but that work is classified
he's won all sorts of prizes for this
work um his work has been selected for
the philosopher's annual which uh
selects the ten best uh philosophy
papers each year he's won a philip
leverhome prize and i think he actually
specializes in academic awards which
have many many syllables
he has won the william james prize for
contributions to the scientific study of
consciousness from the association for
the scientific study of consciousness
[Music]
and last year he won the phi beta kappa
society and american philosophical
association leibowitz prize for
philosophical achievement and
contributions
um this last one was co-awarded with ned
block
and i think usually when prizes in our
fields are co-awarded that means that a
committee couldn't make up their mind or
maybe it was a team but as far as i can
tell you got that prize with ned for
just arguing with him in print about
everything um and really improving our
field uh in the process uh ian is a
model not just of how to make
substantive philosophical contributions
but how to have a dispute in our field
in a like super productive award-winning
way
um in closing i want to suggest that ian
uh is uh
justifiably renowned in all these ways
not just for his substantive
contributions but for the way that he's
doing the philosophy of perception which
is pretty exciting um this shulman
series is about the intersection between
the sciences and the humanities and of
course there's been quite a lot of such
interaction uh generally between
philosophy and psychology but i think
there is a
sort of dark secret in that which is
that there's still quite an asymmetry in
one way
which is that uh increasingly today
there are i think a great many
philosophers who are paying close
careful attention to what's going on in
the psychological literature
but there are really far fewer
psychologists who are paying close
careful attention to what's going on in
the philosophical literature
um
and ian really breaks this mold his work
is of course very well cited in
philosophy which is not so unusual
but what's more special is that his work
is increasingly making a real difference
in racking up all sorts of citations
in psychology and neuroscience
and it's really because he's doing this
work in a different way
as a vision scientist it's sort of easy
to have a love-hate relationship with
the philosophy of perception and that's
in part because so much philosophy of
perception has been done by people who
know about
the mueller liar illusion and that
gorilla experiment
and that's basically all it takes in
fact one of those you could write a book
on it as far as i can tell um but ian
in stark contrast has been really paying
attention to the nitty
uh of all of this work i'm pretty sure
he knows parts of our field uh
better than those of us who are actually
in the trenches doing this work uh and
most importantly he's doing
philosophical work which shows how those
details can really matter as i think
we'll hear about today please welcome
ian phillips
[Applause]
okay thank you so much brian for that
incredibly kind introduction it's a real
honour to be here thank you for coming
in this gorgeous weather
um so today i want to begin with a
passage from the philosopher andy clark
in which he gives voice to what he takes
to be
naive or intuitive though in clark's
view completely false
vision of how our mental lives unfold so
this is what clark says
our human mental life looks to involve a
seamless unfolding of perception action
and experience
a golden braid in which each element
twines intimately with the rest
we see the very world we act in and we
act in the very world we see
but more than this visual experience
presents us with the world in a way apt
for the control and fine guidance of
action
so i think there are kind of three core
ideas here in the clerk
the first is just that all perception is
conscious perception
okay that being the most intimate
entwining of perception and experience
so to see or to hear and so forth is
just to perceptually experience the
world
the second thought is that uh if you
like all worldly action guidance is
perceptual so
um
insofar as the world informs you as an
agent in the course of engaging in some
action it informs us exclusively through
perceptual channels
and the final thought is is something
like this that all perception is
available for action guidance so that's
a kind of minimum
minimal access condition if you like on
on perceptual experience
okay so we see the world we act in we
act in the world we see
now anyone who's at all familiar with
the cognitive science of the last 50
years will know that
it has uncovered what many regard as
repeated and decisive counter examples
to these ideas okay so grounds for
unbraiding this this braid
in particular working cognitive
neuropsychology has witnessed apparent
apparently striking dissociations of
action and awareness and conditions like
blindsight unilateral neglect and visual
for magnosia
and psychophysical work um with
neurotypical subjects has uncovered
extensive evidence of visual processing
in the absence of awareness so most
notably studies of subliminal priming
and also in the domain of visually
guided action
um and over the last several years
i've pressed really a dilemma against
the idea that perception and
consciousness dissociate
which
really divides over a simple question so
take any case where you've allegedly got
some coming apart of perception
experience or action
um how did you measure
uh whether experience was really there
or not how did you establish the absence
of awareness
um
so there are two broad categories of
things you might do you might use
so-called subjective measures or you
might use objective measures
so let's take the first horn
so
if we use so-called subjective measures
to assess awareness so we just simply
are subjects did you see anything or not
or were you conscious of anything or not
then a notorious concern arises
it's often called the problem of the
criterion
it goes back to early signal detection
theorists
and as it manifests in this particular
context it's just the concern that
subjects might underestimate their
conscious experience
and so what i want to do now in the
first sort of substantial chunk of the
talk
is illustrate that concern with respect
to a particular case namely the case of
blind site that brian mentioned
okay so back in the the 70s researchers
most notably larry weiskrantz
at oxford began extensive investigation
of a really astonishing condition which
remains the most discussed
neuropsychological case in both the
contemporary science and philosophy of
consciousness
and this is work if you're interested
that's wonderfully summarized in the
third edition of this landmark book
blind site by weiss crowns
as i'm sure many of you know blindside
is a condition caused by destruction of
an area of the of the brain called
primary visual cortex that's an area at
the back of the brain which is kind of
the first port of call of the first
cortical port of call of visual signals
from the eyes
and here you can see two scans of two
patients
the most extensively investigated
patient gy who has a child had a
road traffic accident leading to a
legion of almost all of v1 primary
visual cortex in his left hemisphere
here
and then a fascinating but much less
explored patient tien who had the
misfortune of having two strokes roughly
30 days apart and so lost um actually
more than just primary visual cortex but
primary visual cortex on on first one
side and then the other side of his
brain so he has bilateral blindside
okay because of your of the organization
of the primate visual system um the
damage to a region of v1 leads to um so
called contralateral or opposite side
field deficits so patient gy here with
the left lesion
has
severe deficits with perception on the
on the right
so given that damage
it's not that surprising you might think
that subjects with blind sight with this
such legions say they're blind in the
corresponding areas so if you ask g why
as he is asked in an interview
what happened to him he just says well
i've lost all the vision to my right
and in the clinic that's confirmed by
what's called perimetry probably an exam
that many of you have had yourselves
where
the clinician just presents in this case
bright
high contrast white stimuli at various
locations in that blind right visual
field
and
what you're seeing here in this kind of
plot
these white circles along the vertical
meridian and at the center here are
cases where gy has said yes by a button
press i saw the uh the the high contrast
stimulus but these black radii are cases
where he said no so it looks to
purposes that he's just blind in the
vast majority of his right visual field
but of course that's not the whole story
there's a huge amount of work on
patients like gy establishing that
there's actually quite extensive visual
function that remains after this damage
so there's evidence of his capacity to
discriminate motion uh in particular
left right or horizontal vertical motion
uh
with another patient studies that show
he's able to discriminate the
orientation of a line or an x from an o
um let's work on effective blind sight
showing that gy can distinguish between
uh happy and sad emotionally expressed
emotions officially express oppressed
emotions
um and again with gy that he can detect
a simple high contrast stimuli in his
blind field
so um i mentioned before patient tn and
this is perhaps the most dramatic
example of preserved visual function so
remember tian has
complete bilateral blind sight so denies
being able to see anything in a
perimetry exam
but this is a video of him
walking down a corridor
and that's wise grant's closely
shadowing him behind
and as you'll see he's able to navigate
these kind of bits of office
paraphernalia that have been put in his
path
pretty effectively despite saying
i have no idea how i did this i'm
completely blind
and this kind of performance
has led many to question kind of what's
the point of being conscious if you can
get around the world like this
without being conscious then why are we
conscious
okay so whatever exactly you think um
extremely common view is that blindside
is is revolutionary so his wise grants
in retrospect describing how
back in the 70s it was just immediately
obvious to him and his colleagues that
the phenomenon of successful performance
without awareness across a startlingly
broad range of visual tasks just must
have a bearing on the neural and
philosophical aspects of consciousness
and and here's a philosopher pat
churchland actually writing in the
context of of wise krantz's work of how
the revolutionary blind site results
just knocked the stuffing out of the
obvious assumption that awareness of a
signal is necessary for an intentional
response to that signal
and that's just part of the golden bread
conception that we need to be aware of
things if we're going to
act in response to them in the world
so first question does blindside show
that the golden braid is mistaken
well in fact there's a simple and
powerful
alternative way of thinking about
blindside
but one i think that's been unjustly
neglected
and so to approach this kind of
alternative picture um notice first that
the tasks used to establish the absence
of awareness and blindside are
subjective measures
so in the perimeter exam i mentioned
before gy is just being asked
you know did you see anything or not
uh following the presentation of a
stimulus
and that kind of question uh is
subject to what is known as conservative
response bias
so let me just illustrate that and i
want you to to think of yourself as a
blind site patient like gy
um
and so
you have
by any objective measure extremely
degraded vision in your right hand
visual field okay so you have pretty
normal vision on your left hand field
that's how you get around the world
normally then your right hand field you
don't see colors you don't really see
visual form at all you don't really see
objects in any real sense maybe you just
have a sense somehow i mean i'm not
saying this is conscious at this point
but just
the objective measures uh are you know
of you being able to detect extremely
high contrast or extremely kind of
salient stimuli only
so the experiment asks you
after the presentation of some stimulus
did you see anything on that trial
and what are you supposed to make of
that question
you might think maybe this is sort of
somewhat philosophical kind of question
um and philosophers do not agree on the
answer to this question um what does it
take to see something what does it mean
to see something i mean that's just
being handed over to me to make a
decision about that
how sure do i have to be that what has
just happened to me counts as a case of
seeing how sure do i have to be there
was a stimulus there to say yes and so
on
maybe you think something like this well
the experience i had was just nothing
like seeing something in my sighted
field so quotes normal seeing so i
should probably say no
or you might think well i had some
really vague awareness but i wouldn't
say i saw anything specific so i guess
i'll say no
or you might think i'm not sure whether
i saw something or not so maybe i'll
play it safe and i'll say no
okay so for all of those reasons and
many others um
uh
you might think
uh
a negative response in an exam like this
needn't be taken as
a guarantee that there was absolutely no
awareness
because there's this other factor namely
all that decisional thinking that goes
on after your experience that we need to
take into account
okay so that's the the tasks that are
used to assess awareness what about the
tasks that are used to assess residual
visual capacity
well these are typically so-called
forced choice or maybe force response
tasks
um and these are effectively at least
the first choice task effectively bias
free
so let me say what i mean by by that
so in a forced choice task you're
presented with uh in a two alternative
case two temporal or spatial intervals
um so there's going to be a stimulus in
just one of those two intervals
and you have to choose which
and so here i mean i no idea how these
slides appear to you whether it's
completely obvious to you that there's a
a patch in one and not in the other
but suppose
they were
presented to you on their own and you
might think i don't think i can see
anything in either of those
um so each indiv interval presented on
its own is one such that you would say
no i don't see anything
but you don't have that option here of
saying
no there's nothing there i don't see
anything you have to choose which of
these the stimulus is in
and you know there is a stimulus in one
of them so what you do when you
naturally pick whichever interval it is
that's most likely to contain a stimulus
perhaps you might think that which just
gave you that dimmest flicker or hint of
awareness of there being something there
okay so
you might think that
but you have to choose so you think
maybe there was something faint in the
first and you go for that
so i hope it's clear even from this
brief presentation that these forced
choice tasks are kind of
a great tool for a psychophysicist to
ascertain a subject sensitivity
independent of their bias because bias
doesn't really factor into this unless
you have a particular preference for
interval ones over interval twos there's
no question of conservative criterion
coming in
okay so that kind of framework sets up
the thought that actually all the data
concerning blindside is consistent with
a picture on which what the brain damage
has done
is to severely and maybe qualitatively
degrade the subject's vision in their
blind field perhaps to the point where
it's just too weak or degraded or
qualitatively different to count to them
as seeing
as i say there's no color no form no
objects and so on
but nonetheless there is a conscious
signal there which is sufficient to
perform above chance when you force the
subject to make a decision between two
alternatives
so i can't give a full defense of that
viewpoint here but i just want to give
you three sort of you know almost you
know tantalizing teaser bits of evidence
that make me think this hypothesis is on
the right lines
so one important thing to notice is that
um
blind sight patients do report awareness
especially when the question is changed
subtly
and what you think what i think maybe
the question changes about is
this the question change elicits a
different more liberal criteria in the
subject so they're more prepared to say
yes to this question than the others so
here i mentioned slightly misleadingly
that this was uh the perimetry plot from
this paper and it is the classic
preliminary plot in all the early papers
on blindside that's you know the kind of
plot you see for gy
but these experimentalists also asked a
different question with just the same
stimuli in a second block so that
different question was just pressed when
you're aware of something so we had
press when you see something
nothing press when you're aware of
something and suddenly you get all these
positive responses
okay so there's clearly some kind of
awareness
in much of the visual field if you trust
these answers
second kind of bit of evidence um
usually blindside patients in these
experiments are given a binary uh
choice between yes and no
responses they can either say yes i saw
it or no i didn't see it
but what happens when we give a
blindside subject a more fine-grained
response uh scale
so this is a study done by matsy and
colleagues
with a different patient a woman called
sl
and what they did was just give her a
batch of different discrimination tasks
like orientation and color and so on
discrimination tasks and after every
trial asked her
did you do that task by seeing the
stimulus or were you just guessing
so a standard yes no measure
and what they found was that in the the
black bars indicate uh i was just
guessing so no responses that only in
one of the cases uh here uh did she
acknowledge that she was seeing anything
and that that was driving her
her responses but then again they did
exactly the same discrimination tasks
but affording her the the luxury of
being able to respond in four different
ways so she could say i had no
experience i had weak experience i had
uh almost clear experience or i had
clear experience
and this is what happened
it turned out that the the black bars
which are indicating guest responses so
no i didn't have any experiences
actually look like they comprised both
zero so no experience but also this dark
gray i.e week experience
and similarly the the yes i saw
something corresponds here to
her
almost clear experience so it looks like
what the subject has been doing with
that yes no is using no to mean
none or weak and the yes to mean
clear or almost clear
and it's a little hard to tell too much
from this particular study because the
performance is quite low across the
board but there was no evidence of above
chance performance just looking at the
cases where
no experience at all was reported that
had to at least be weak experience
before reported before and got any
performance
okay final bit of
of of teaser evidence
this is from a study by uh zakian fish
of um of gy
and they gave him a whole bunch of
different kind of conditions and in
particular in one particular very low
contrast condition
he just spontaneously responds and he
knows his experiment is very well
hey my awareness score in this
particular block should be quotes minus
one or minus two
and i think what that really tells you
is that his zero was not absolutely zero
if he's prepared to give minus one and
minus two responses okay so in general i
hope that gives you some sense
um that the the judgments of awareness
are one should be suspicious about and
it turns out that they
uh there is awareness there if you
really find the right ways at it
and i think there's a case to be made
that that correlates quite well with
with performance also
but if you want a really systematic and
sustained defense of that view against
lots of psychophysical objections
then uh let me advertise this paper
okay what everyone thinks of blind site
the residual vision is really very
limited so you know there are sometimes
anecdotes about how a blind sighted
patient wouldn't reach out for a glass
of water if they were thirsty well
that's because they can't see objects i
mean there's no there's no vision
capable of
of anything like that kind of richness
but in the 80s researchers interested in
a rather different condition reported
evidence of as they put it
unconscious perceptual analysis far more
extensive than a dreamt of in most
current theories and the most current
theories were precisely the theories
that were being motivated by by
blindside
so this is evidence from a condition
called neglect
a neglect is a really complicated and
kind of fractionated disorder it's
associated to
much later damage in the individual
hierarchy um so typically it follows a
stroke and
it's associated with damage to kind of
right uh inferior parietal and temporary
parietal regions
and it's characterized by a failure to
respond or report or
attend to or orient to significant
stimuli on the other side of space
where that's not due to you know
you not being able to see in some
elementary sense there's no damage to
uh your eyes or very early visual areas
naught of being able to respond in
the kind of other end of things in a
motor way
and you often see these kinds of
pictures in textbooks so this is a
picture of
a house and the patient has just been
asked to copy it and you can see they've
just failed to copy out the left-hand
side
here they've been asked to bisect a line
and you can see that they've bisected it
too far to the right as if they're
ignoring this part of the line
and this classic line cancellation task
is a case where the patient just in free
vision has been asked to strike through
all the lines they can see
and they've not done that with the ones
on the left at all but they've
repeatedly done it with the ones on the
right
okay so here's a really classic study
not really a case report rather than a
study
that it was the beginning of a much more
extensive body of work but i just want
to talk about the simple study partly
because it's the one that's always cited
still and you know widely discussed even
to this day
um i just read hachman lao's new book on
consciousness which is a really
interesting book and it talks about this
study
and it suffices i think to make the
basic point about a lot of the work
so here a patient called ps with severe
neglect we've shown these two houses
just on cards and asked the following
questions are these houses the same or
different
and she says they're the same
uh is there anything wrong with either
card no
okay but which house would you prefer to
live in
and understandably she says that's a
silly question
um but when forced to make a response
she chooses this non-burning one on nine
of the eleven trials okay that's why
it's not a study but just the nine of
the eleven trials um but you know this
is someone who's just had a stroke
probably
okay what the the do the authors say
well they say that these preference
judgments clearly indicate covert
knowledge without conscious perceptual
awareness
showing unconscious perception analysis
far more extensive as i said than is
dreamt of in our current theories
and so what are they thinking what
they're presumably thinking that she's
seeing these flames
you can see this house is a burning
house that's what's driving her
preference judgment but that can't be
conscious because otherwise she would
have said they were different or
something was wrong with the two houses
the problem here again though is that
these questions are very very different
questions to be asking someone if you
ask the question or two things the same
or different you need yourself to make
up your mind like well how different the
two things have to be before i count
them as different
um uh
you know how much difference did there
have to be
similarly if you're asked the question
is there anything wrong with either card
you have to make up your mind well how
much has to be wrong before i say
something is wrong what is it to be
what is it for something to be wrong
with something
okay so these are questions that are
both biased in the sense that subjects
show a tendency to say the same
even when there are visible differences
between stimuli
so that would be a kind of way of being
conservative towards making different
judgments
uh and again you might expect people to
be conservative and saying something was
wrong because um they might be hesitant
to do that
in contrast this is slightly unusual but
it's a forced choice question you have
to pick one of these two houses
so you don't have the option of saying
well i don't really care when she does
say that but then she's forced to guess
so
once we see that the pattern of
responses here and in future experiments
is just fully consistent with a picture
on which what neglect has led to is some
kind of degraded conscious awareness of
the left-hand side of this object or the
left-hand side of space
maybe just something being a bit off
with one of the houses or something
being slightly smudgy over there or an
asymmetry in the stimulus
um and that's not sufficient to drive a
different or yes response but it is to
to bias
to lead her to make this preference
judgment so i mean maybe it's a bit like
this
i don't know whether you can see
anything in the left hand side of space
there but that's just this kind of
slight smudging
okay
so let's go back to
our dilemma so that's subjective
measures and how they crop up in two
kind of critical cases but what if we
adopt a more rigorous objective test of
awareness and insist that a stimulus
just has to be completely undetectable
earth to count as unconscious
that would rule out blindside and
neglect as cases of unconscious
perception or at least clear cases of
such
um but it would also overcome this
problem of the criterion
okay so
if we do that then i think a different
issue arises and the key point here is
if the subject cannot detect the
stimulus we need some other way of
showing that they've seen it
and a standard way of doing that would
be to do
a priming study and show some priming
effects so we might present the subject
with this arrow here
mask it shortly afterwards in such a way
that perhaps the prime is undetectable
and then follow it up with a consciously
perceived target to which we ask the
subject to respond in some way so maybe
they just press left or right and it
turns out that their right responses are
marginally faster when a congruent right
prime has been preceded
has preceded it
okay let's assume we do get such effects
the issue though here is that the
priming effect itself can be understood
simply in terms of the automatic
activation of some
subsystem of the individual so maybe
their visual system or maybe their
visual motor system you can think of
this prime as you know activating
representations in your early visual
areas that are since activated uh
will lead to this target being perceived
slightly faster
if they're congruent as opposed to
inconcurrent or maybe the motor response
has been activated and so you're
slightly faster to fire it off when you
see this target
but perception isn't the state of your
primary visual cortex or of your you
know supplementary motor area or any of
these parts of your your brain or nor
even of a cognitive subsystem of yours
it's a state that you're in you're the
perceiver you perceive things
so we can't just conclude from an effect
that shows an effect on a subsystem that
you yourself have perceived something
so i call this a problem of attribution
you know it's like i think an extremely
difficult question as to how we should
solve this problem like what are the
marks of the individual level um
but i kind of widely agreed mark and i
say mark advisedly because you know many
people would say wasn't necessary or
sufficient but just a good guide
of the individual level
is if a state or an episode or
representation is directly available to
guide action so if a subject can use
that representation to make some choice
or to guide their action in some uh
purposive way
then we should think of it as an
individual level representation
and these primes aren't available to do
that
so the action is guided by this target
here
uh these simply modulate the way you end
up responding to this in some
modest way
but as a result of this kind of dilemma
in the setup a lot of the debate and
brian mentioned ned so you know here are
some of the many things i've written in
debate with ned about these issues has
really come to focus on this issue of
unconscious action guidance so the
reason for that is that um if we could
find compelling evidence of unconscious
action guidance that gets around the
problem of the of attribution and so
does provide a case of
uh kind of a clear counter example to
the golden braid
and these are some other papers which
again by josh shepherd and metamopoulos
and jake berger which again kind of
press the same thought
so in the last part of the talk i want
to talk about a couple of these cases
okay so in the background here is a
a canonical framework for thinking about
um
visual motor action
due to mel goodale and david milner here
called this local two visual systems
hypothesis
and very very roughly this hypothesis
says that when visual signal
goes on from primary visual cortex it
proceeds in two anatomically and
functionally separate streams
okay the first pathway
which is a kind of a ventral pathway
here
milder and good l dub vision for
perception
since in their view it is responsible
for the construction of conscious
representations of our environment
representations which gets stored in
memory and then used for you know making
judgments recognizing categorizing and
also uh uh thinking about the world and
planning future actions
and the second pathway here that the
that milo goodell called vision for
action
um
and which is claimed to be responsible
for the online control of our visually
guided actions so reaching and grasping
and so on
and a critical part of this framework
has it that the information in this
dorsal stream is completely unconscious
okay
in principle cannot be accessed
consciously
there's been hugely inflammation in
philosophy i won't read out these
quotations but um
uh here's andy clark
you know this the context of his
rejection of the golden braid is
precisely this
insisting that
the involvement of
this dorsal information in our online
action control is just completely
immense and pervasive again raising a
question about why we need to be
conscious at all
here's brett brogard saying something
very similar
arguing that actually we're never really
consciously aware of exactly what we're
doing because all of what we're doing at
the moment is being guided by the dorsal
stream
that's not to say there's not been
pushback in
philosophy um so the very nice paper by
um john schwenkler and rob briscoe from
a few years ago uh saying that there's
the two visual systems hypothesis too
too crude
that there's plenty of evidence that the
spatial contents of visual experience
are eventual stream representations are
in fact involved in online motor
guidance and programming
but even they are not interested in
objecting to the idea that there's just
masses of empirical evidence that there
are non-conscious sources of information
that do significantly influence our
bodily actions
okay so
why think that the dorsal stream
representation is unconscious
i think there are two
basic reasons and so here's josh
sheppard and metampolis asking and
answering that question
citing these two sources they say
the first source of evidence involves
visual motor pointing tasks and the
second involves this case of visual for
magnosia
in particular patient df so let me just
talk about those
this is actually a really old body of
work it's one of the luxuries being a
philosopher is that you can you know
site work from 50 years ago and that's
okay but i think it's really important
to go back to the foundations of these
things and reassess them sometimes so
this is what it goes back to bruce
bridgeman in the early 80s um i guess it
kind of came to its uh uh you know full
uh
you know
flourishing with mark gennaro here um
mel goodell did a bunch of this work um
there's a huge research program here
and it's still widely appealed to you by
philosophers but here are two classic
tasks
so in this task from goodal palestine
problem from 86
um
you the subject will be sat in front of
a target
and your task is to
uh wait for that target to to jump to
your right
and then to reach out immediately and
point to it
so the target's going to jump you point
to it
in 50 of the trials though the target is
going to jump an extra 10 percent you're
not told about this but this is just the
case so it's going to jump an extra
three to five
centimeters
just as you're circading just as you're
moving your eyes to that target
so under these conditions subjects never
notice that there is any extra jump it's
time to coincide with their eye
movements so it's kind of hidden
but nonetheless they adjust their
trajectory as if the target had
basically immediately gone to that
location so there's just no difference
in the trajectories of the jump targets
as opposed to one that was sent there
originally
and on that basis goodale and colleagues
say
look this is just a clear demonstration
that the neural mechanisms mediating the
perception of target position can be
dissociated from those
mediating visually guided reaching
movements a dissociation reminiscent of
the behavior of cortically blind
patients such a repeated refrain in this
literature that blindside has set up
something that constantly gets referred
back to
okay here's the second experiment very
similar
by castiello and colleagues from marx
general's lab
um
you as a subject again sat in front of
some targets this time they're these
translucent dowels which can be
illuminated
and your task
uh initially is just to
wait for the dow to light up and then
reach out towards it and also to make
the sound tar just to say tar out loud
just just a meaning meaningless
vocalization
but in the critical session
trials all began with the second dow
being illuminated
um but then in the minority and 20 of
the trials the the light would jump to
the left or to the right
um subjects were told this would happen
and in these perturbated trials they
were instructed to just track the shift
so instead of going to the middle one
now go left or right
um and then say tar again to indicate
that they'd consciously experience the
visual change that had taken place
okay so second one goes on you say tar
immediately then it jumps and then you
say tar again and reach out to it
looking at the um
the motor correction that occurs in this
study um the experimental
experimentalist established that the
reaction time i the time it takes
between the jump happening and the the
hand trajectory changing is about 100
milliseconds
but the vocal reaction time was much
longer nearly 420 milliseconds on
average
so it took nearly you know well over 300
milliseconds for sub between the the
change in the uh the movement
and the vocalization to come
and indeed on some occasions they report
the dissociation was so
uh striking
that the throne surprise subjects were
already lifting the the first or third
dowel
by the time they were emitting that
vocal response
so what does this show
well the thought is uh that's given in
the paper is that this extra 300
milliseconds is the time required for
conscious perceptual experience to be
generated
but you don't need conscious perceptual
experience to guide your uh actions
those are guided by this other system
that what later becomes uh identified as
this uh
vision for action pathway
so again with these results are said to
show a clear dissociation between motor
responses and awareness like blindside
and you know this is from a textbook
this picture and that's what the
textbook tells you it's possible to
dissociate behavior and conscious
awareness
but i think there's a much simpler
explanation of what's going on in these
tasks
and to see this just reflect that in
order to accurately point or reach out
towards a target you only have to
represent its current location you don't
care where it was or where it will be
you just need to know where it is now in
the moment
but that does not suffice for you to
detect a change to detect a change you
need to do a whole bunch of other things
especially if that change has been
hidden from you by occurring during a
cicade
you need to encode the original location
of the target you need to maintain that
representation you need to retrieve it
when the new occasion comes around and
you need to compare those two
representations so there's a whole
sequence of steps that need take to take
place if you're going to accurately
judge there's been a change
okay and so to kind of give you a sense
of that and if you've seen this before i
apologize but do you want to indulge me
by staring at the next slide for 30
seconds
and see if you spot anything unusual
okay um
so
maybe i've spotted it by just saying
that but this was the the final slide
you saw
and i don't know whether any of you
realize who hadn't seen it before but
this was the original slide okay so
massive change in color if you're
anything like me you did not notice when
you first saw this okay
but the last thing that you want to
conclude from this is that we don't see
colors okay um
what this shows you presumably is that
you can accurately represent the color
of something at any particular moment
even though you fail across time to do
that whole procedure of uh um
maintaining retrieving and comparing
accurately
um
okay so this is just a classic example
of change blindness and the point to be
made about change minus is that the
failures most of the change doesn't in
itself mean you didn't see the
particular feature that changed at the
moment um before or after the change
and i really think the same thing is
going on here the failure to notice an
extra jump in the target doesn't mean
that you don't consciously perceive the
target position effectively throughout
the experiment
so there's not a clear demonstration
here of a dissociation between
mechanisms
mediating the perception of target
position and those mediating the
visually guided reaching movements
um
both
might be accurate representations of the
current target position what there's
been a failure of is a failure to detect
a change
but that wasn't necessary to do uh the
the reaching task
and nor is it necessary to see the
accurate position of the target
consciously
and the same i think is true here the
course correction reflects that you've
accurately updated the
your representation of the target's
current location like where the light
currently is
but remember tar was meant to be the
signal of your conscious experience of a
visual change so have you detected and
and
are you do you feel able to judge that a
change has occurred and you might then
think that that detection process
requires some extra time to go through
some of those processing steps the
retrieval the comparison and so on and
that's what's explaining that delay not
the
time needed for conscious experience so
again i don't think there's evidence for
dissociation here
okay um let me now just finally talk
about the second set of evidence so
and again this is going to be extremely
brief and extremely uh
you know narrow but i'm more than happy
to talk about other cases in the q a
um
so
patient df who has this condition called
visual for magnosia
uh suffered very badly actually from um
carbon monoxide poisoning
and it had sort of extensive lesions but
in particular
uh she has extensive lesions on both
sides to her ventral stream so remember
the stream that menorah goodell called
vision for perception that's associated
with these conscious representations of
our
visual environment
and she's not blind because v1 was
largely spared and
she can see color she can see texture
but she has real problems
with object recognition she struggles to
see size shape orientation and so forth
and just to give you some sense of that
here's an imaging study
in which she and her controls um are
shown these line drawings and uh the
activity elicited uh in these ventral
pathways when presented with these line
drawings is compared to the scrambled
versions here
and so in the control subjects you can
see there's extensive differential
activity in presence of this bed and
this pepper compared to the scrambling
but in df there's absolutely no
uh differential activity
to be seen
and yet despite that she appears to have
really quite impressive abilities for
visually guided action
so let me just talk about one particular
case of that
very famous experiment done by milan and
godel back in the 90s early 90s where
df was just asked to
look at this orientable slot
and do one of two things either to
hold a card and at a distance match the
orientation of the slot with the card
or reach out and post it through the
slot
okay
and
i'll show you a video if i'm doing this
in a sec but um here's the the person of
data
she's incredibly bad at this matching
task um
these are kind of normalized to the
vertical but um but you can see that
her performance there is almost random
whereas in the visual motor posting task
she's not perfect or not exactly like
control subjects but incredibly close
so this is the standard story that's
then told about this pattern of data and
his this is a quotation from from ned
block df is almost as good as posting as
our normal controls but nearly random at
matching what explains this well her
conscious mind can't see orientation
that's why she can't do the matching
task
nonetheless it must be the orientation
that's perceived otherwise how could she
do the posting task well that must be
perceived in this unconscious
action-guiding part of her brain
so here is her doing the matching task
let me just show you one example of that
when you can already see this is i'll
just wait for the experimenter to
reorient the
the slot
okay and now she's being asked to
to match
okay so
and this goes on and every time there's
really no relation you can see between
the
okay but here's the more impressive
thing
here is a case of uh the slot being
moved and helping us to reach out and
post through it
okay so really a remarkable
dissociation
problem is again there's an alternative
explanation of what's going on um
uh
and the thing is that needs recognizing
is that you don't need to be able to
perceive orientation to do the posting
task and that's because there's another
way of doing it
you can succeed in posting by using
what's called an obstacle avoidance
strategy
and what that involves is you seeking to
minimize the distances between the edges
of the slot and the edges of the card
sorry maximize the distance it's not
minimized so if you can create maximum
safety margin or you know
room between the edges of the slot and
the edges of the card you will post
successfully
and in fact you don't actually you know
orientation is kind of neither necessary
nor efficient sufficient for doing the
task if you're if you know the
orientation you still can't do the task
unless you know the midpoint
um but if you don't know the orientation
and you do know
uh like
that
as held like this you've managed to
maximize the distances between the card
and the slot edge then you will be able
to do the task
so this strategy is strictly orientation
free
okay but is there any evidence this is
what's actually going on
well the first piece of evidence that
was proposed for this account um comes
from a paper by hess franz and schenck
from 2011 and what they do is they
modify the slot
so that um
actually the orientation whether it's
the maximum safety margin is not the
vertical of the slot but it's diagonal
so it's a wide slot but they use very
big cards
and what they find this is just
neurotypical subjects
is that the orientation error
namely the departure from that vertical
is pretty large in about half of the
subjects suggesting that about half of
the the subjects do in fact post through
this slot with
a non
not orienting to the to the slots
orientation but rather maximizing the
safety margin
and interestingly there's no relation
between their matching behavior and
whether they do that or whether they
stick to this
uh strategy or not so this is some
suggestive evidence
but in response to this um
block in particular but others too have
been rather unimpressed they say well
this is just very weak evidence this is
a very weak criticism of the original
study
for three reasons one
look that a task that's been
deliberately designed to elicit obstacle
avoidance does so in normal subjects
doesn't show anything about what df is
doing
second as you saw in the video i showed
you df moves our hand forward
unhesitatingly and almost always inserts
the card smoothly into the slot block
says
and she also begins to rotate the card
towards the correct orientation when in
advance of arriving at it
and finally he says that he thinks
orientation perception would be required
to avoid hitting the edge of the slot
with a card i just think that's not
correct although i don't he doesn't say
any more than this so i don't know
precisely the thinking but i do not
think it's true that you need
orientation to succeed in this task
with respect to this criticism i think
this would be correct as a criticism um
if there was somehow an obvious
difference between the the subjects who
did who used the strategy in the his
paper but actually they also if you look
at the details all
had adjusted the card to that as it were
diagonal orientation
by midway through their trajectories and
they they all posted smoothly and
effortlessly in a similar way so
really the key point here is that this
difference in strategy doesn't predict
that you wouldn't be able to do
uh
a smooth posting movement or that you
wouldn't be able to get the orientation
in advance it's just the difference in
the information being used
but the first point is i think
absolutely right that we can't
generalize too much from this early
study
but i now think there's stronger
evidence and this comes from um the same
group
from a much more recent paper
and it exploits an effect known as the
oblique effect
so all of us
are reliably more accurate in judging
horizontal and vertical orientations
than
um uh oblique orientation so you know
cardinal orientations are just if you
look around the room you'll see they're
all over the place we're very very used
to them and our visual systems are very
used to them so we're better at
discriminating horizontals and verticals
than
oblique orientations
so if posting were to be based on
orientation you'd expect it to show an
oblique effect
if it's based on an obstacle avoidance
strategy which is orientation free you
wouldn't
so just as proof of concept here's
evidence from a matching paradigm which
does show an oblique effect so in both
these two conditions here the open loop
means the subjects can't see the target
as soon as they've begun the movement so
that's why the errors are larger you're
seeing errors
um in the matching of an orientation and
you can see they're much lower with the
horizontal and verticals here than with
the obliques
what about posting
no such effect
okay there is a pattern in this data
though and which some of you know that
will have spotted looks like um errors
are increasing in this direction well
that's because they all started from us
at the same
kind of post horizontal rotation
position
so we can fix that as the
experimentalists did by using variable
starting positions and we can also do
one other thing that's important we can
introduce a delay between
the presentation of the target and the
action being made and that's important
because
it's natural to worry or think that
maybe the two visual assistants people
will say but maybe the dorsal stream
maybe your action guiding stream doesn't
have an oblique effect associated with
it maybe that's just a ventral stream
thing
but those people goodell and milner do
think that once you introduce a delay
our actions fall back on ventral stream
representations so action guiding
representations are supposed to be kind
of on the fly in the moment
representations which are used in online
guidance but when we're falling back on
memory
we use the ventral stream so
um this
delay ought to definitely get us
an oblique effect if there is one to be
found
of course here's the matching data again
showing such an effect but here's the
posting data again showing no such
effect
so this is all data from neurotypical
subjects but what this is really
suggesting is that neurotypical subjects
don't use orientation
uh information primarily in guiding
their
uh posting we're using obstacle
avoidance strategies
okay so in general subjects use
orientation free obstacle avoidance
strategies or at least i mean that
really is evidence that their
orientation free not specifically their
obstacle avoidance but
in their posting and so our default
hypothesis now should be that df is
doing that
if that's right then her performance on
the posting class clearly doesn't
establish that she's perceived the
orientation of the slot in an
unconscious action guiding part of her
brain the simplest thing to say is that
you just can't see orientation
okay i've i'm over the
time that i said i would speak for so
i'm going to wrap up now but there's a
huge number of other bits of evidence
that i could have mentioned
but this is a real take-home i want to
to leave you with
what i've argued is that across a very
diverse range of cases
and for a whole set of different reasons
these apparently striking associations
of performance and awareness that you
have seen in blindside and neglect
um
may in fact be specious or artifactual
in different ways so in the case of
blindside neglect it was the problem the
criterion which i pointed to
in the case of subliminal priming it's
not so much the effect is spacious or
artifactual there it's that the there's
a gap between the data and what it shows
and the uh anything that the golden
braid is talking about namely perception
by us and our actions
in the case of those visual motor action
studies the point was that there's a
conflation or a misunderstanding of what
uh is
being shown by failure to detect change
it doesn't show that we're not tracking
a feature
and in the case of visual magnosia and
this would apply to many other studies
of visual magnesia there are just
different strategies that can be used to
do different tasks
and so when you compare two tasks you
need to be very very sure that the same
strategy is being applied in both
okay this then returns us to this naive
vision i began with
which clark paints
on which perception is always conscious
and always available for action guidance
and all action guidance
occurs with conscious perception and
i'm not really standing here today
saying this is the truth
what i am trying to stand here and say
is that this is our starting point and
we shouldn't abandon it without
extremely good evidence and the evidence
that i've surveyed i don't think is
decisive uh evidence
so not everything that's naive or
intuitive uh uh should be given up upon
okay thank you very much for listening
[Applause]
so um thank you ian that was fantastic
and um
thank you very much ian's extremely
interesting paper
um in your debate with ned block
i find myself wondering what you regard
as the minimal condition would it be
true that something is conscious or
aware of anything
um it seems though you and block had a
clear idea of what it was to be
consciously aware of something and
you're arguing about that but looking at
the data one might wonder whether first
of all awareness isn't a matter of
degree
secondly word is vague and certainly
whether there is a determinant cut off
point at the bottom level
so i was wondering whether you could say
what you regard as the minimal condition
for the presence of consciousness to be
yeah thanks um i mean that's a huge
question with many questions built into
it so um
maybe one answer is just i can't give
you an answer that question so i think
there is a slight difference between us
and but also a bit of agreement so i
think we're both agreed that the
interest is in phenomenal consciousness
both ned and i um
but i am inclined to impose a kind of
access condition on that which was an
action condition i mentioned so
i guess i think one
condition that
is a plausible condition for
representation being conscious is that
it's
you know usable by the subject in some
way and i don't think that um
the ned will necessarily well i'm pretty
sure he wouldn't agree with that they
might be happy with the idea that there
are conscious representations that just
are completely inaccessible
um
then there's a question of of degrees
um
[Music]
i mean i do think there's a way in which
we can make sense of of consciousness or
at least of a certain kind of episode as
being more or less conscious
but i also think there's there's that
doesn't that's not inconsistent with it
being
either true or false that it is a
conscious episode or not i when we talk
about degraded vision or a very very
weak signal i think that gives us some
operational grip on
um
uh it being a
conscious to a low degree as it were but
i still think it's there's a matter of
fact about whether it's conscious or not
and then
you know might it be indeterminate or
might it be vague
i don't want to rule that out at all
um nothing i've said is
committed to that and i don't really
know if that's
there's anything in our naive or
intuitive view which says
um
there's always a determinant fact of the
matter
but um
i mean feel free to press me more on
things i've just said or um
um i wanted to i found this all very
convincing um but i'm not familiar with
debates but it's still convincing but
what what do you think motivates people
like black to uh insist that performance
and awareness can be dissociated um is
what's in it for them as it were
in taking this line is there a
philosophical motivation or is there
something that they're not concerned
with that you're concerned with that
they can explain this difference
that's a really interesting question um
i don't i mean i i i feel like i
shouldn't try and peer into
um ned's soul or um but i kind of think
there's a it's particularly interesting
in his case because
he has this distinction between
phenomenal and access consciousness
and once you've got that distinction you
might think well why not think that many
of these cases are cases are phenomenal
without some form of access i so that
was in ways the question that first got
me interested in this
area and
it's kind of a question for finnett
so he has nonetheless though
decided that
as he sees the evidence it points to a
kind of tripartite distinction between
this unconscious
uh truly unconscious phenomenally
conscious and access consciousness
um i mean i do think he's seriously
guided by the empirical evidence in this
case and so
i think that's what he would reply and
very reasonably so many many people
actually with very different views of
consciousness to his
see these cases as being
um
you know absolutely clear demonstrations
of of things
um
so
i mean i i
in ways i i think there's a kind of a
really legitimate
deference to to science that's going on
in a lot of philosophy
but i think there's also an insufficient
attention to the assumptions that are
going into the interpretation of these
studies which is what i'm so
maybe there shouldn't have been quite so
much
in my view
hi um thank you so much for the talk i
have to confess i'm very new to all of
this so
i wanted to ask a very basic question
um so it seemed that the golden braid is
tying together three
things perception conscious perception
and action-guidingness
and it seemed like the the debates over
the evidence was about whether it's
conscious perception that's action
guiding or whether we have unconscious
perception that's acting action guiding
and i wondered if you could say
something about the link between
perception and acting guidingness
in general such that
i'm not quite sure how to articulate it
can the two be pulled apart or is there
something about the way in which we
investigate psychologically where it
can't be pulled apart because we're
looking at people's behaviors and as
we've ruled out the subjective measures
what happens there
yeah that's a that's a really good
question i mean i think there's
something slightly terminological here
um
so
when milner and goodell say that
this visual stream that guides action is
vision for action they contrast it with
vision for perception so as they're
talking about perception they're talking
about something that's conscious or at
least potentially conscious so
then the
question is all action guidance
perceptual is a real one because
we're getting this
contrast between
information that's coming in
as it were through the senses that's
genuinely perceptual
and information which isn't because it's
going with this dorsal pathway
and my first move was to say
as part of the golden braid all
perception
is conscious
and then you can't the contrast that
they have
can't exist at that point
so your question then becomes well is
there anything else is there any other
source of information
that could be action guiding that wasn't
perceptual
um
now i actually think that it's not
totally obvious there there isn't but it
would be some kind of as it were extra
sensory information that
was guiding our actions in an online way
and i don't know what exactly that would
be
um so you know
i'm not actually certain it's in in the
golden braid that that's all ruled out
but
i don't think it's part of our naive
conception that there are other ways of
information coming in that aren't via
the sensors that
are available for action guidance of
course there's information that's stored
and used
independently of current perception that
guides our action we can act as it were
on the basis of that
did you have anything in mind or um
no i didn't have anything in mind but i
was wondering so the direction you're
going is uh
whether
perception like what are the sources for
action guiding this
and i was wondering about the other
direction such that could you just have
perception that isn't action guiding in
some way
or maybe i just don't know what it means
for something to be action guiding and
the relevance yeah you're right so the
the kind of cases that someone like
block might point to were alleged cases
where you have perception
um conscious perception but that's
inaccessible
um
might count as cases where
there's those representations although
they contribute to what it's like to be
you they're conscious
and not
available for
for guiding actions
i happen to think there aren't any
obvious such cases but um
that's that's not really something i
spoke
at all significantly about today
one last question
i'll try to make it quick
it's a methodological question
why where are the qualitative data
sources on these conditions i i thought
it might be much easier to adjudicate
between the golden braid view and blocks
view by just asking people who have
blindside what is your experience like
rather than putting them through these
complicated tests so where's the
qualitative data here is there some
barrier to interpreting qualitative data
that it's not easy to see
or um
yeah
yeah so that's a good question um
so i have
looked very hard to to kind of assemble
you know subjective reports of what it's
like to have blind sight in the
literature and there are a bunch
actually so the the claim that dui makes
an interview that he's lost all vision
to his right is undermined by his own
reports when he says things like
um
you know sometimes i can see orientation
but then i lose all form or or you know
as if there's some
um
kind of failures of you know might
describe it as like a failure of binding
of features that you can see one type of
feature at a time he sometimes talks
about how his vision is
a bit like
what a normally cited
what he's aswed man
would experience if they were looking
out at a bright
light with their eyes closed and waved
their hand between the light and their
hand or something like that um and he
uses these lovely phrases like like
black on black like a mouse under a
blanket
so he has these evocative descriptions
of his own experience so there is
qualitative and it's also this amazing
paper though that um
uh
i think really does expose
what might be problematic about some of
this data
um so it's actually a it's a hack one
loud paper um and it's a super
interesting approach but i think at
least the philosophers in the room will
smile at it so what they decided they
needed to do with patient gy who's
really the most extensively study paper
was get gy to understand what qualia are
so they got these passages from you know
the stanford encyclopedia of philosophy
from like jackson and ty and whoever
and um
you know read this and he's a very you
know dedicated subject and reads his own
literature so um
he read the philosophical riches and do
you have these
and if you look at what he was given he
was actually given these kinds of the
bright blue the pacific ocean that you
know the fresh smell of coffee in the
morning kind of descriptions of quality
and so what he said was no i don't
except on the very like high contrast
trials basically
um so
but but
so i i just think this problem the
criterion is is present in in any kind
of
subjective report it's just the
psychophysical work
uses it in a much narrow and more
controlled environment
[Applause]